I'll let you finish but Beyonce had one
of the best videos of all time I'm just
assuming that this
whole thing was a practice and rehearse
skit yeah because why else would Kanye
West be jumping up on the stage
interrupting Taylor Swift I think people
try things on the VMAs they would never
try anywhere else in 2009 Taylor Lautner
was a top-lining pop culture phenomenon
and got to present an award to his music
Superstar girlfriend Taylor Swift what
could go wrong probably should have said
something well as he remembers
everything why you gotta be so mean the
actor breaks it all down on his podcast
The Squeeze which he co-hosts with his
wife also named Taylor if you can go
back to One Moment in your life what
moment would that be probably the 2009
VMAs and was unaware that the Kanye
thing was not a skit I never actually
thought that would have happened oh just
wait t-swift I was standing on stage and
I was really excited because I had just
one on the award I took you know five
steps back and was standing five feet
behind her and
um yeah in the middle of her giving her
thank you speech Kanye jumps up onto the
stage and then I was really excited
because Kanye West was on the stage and
then I wasn't so excited anymore I'm
really happy for you I'll let you finish
but Beyonce had one of the best videos
of all time I can barely hear it I can't
see them I'm just assuming that this
whole thing was a practice and rehearse
skit right so it just didn't make sense
I don't know him and I don't want to
start anything because I just you know I
had a great night tonight if you look
back at it I'm actually caught like
laughing and like giggling at him like I
can't hear them but this is probably
really funny right now the second she
turned back around and I saw her face
for the first time I was like oh
probably should have said something I've
been getting so many text messages it's
like and and everybody's been really
nice so I've had a really really fun
night it's been interesting definitely
it's definitely been an interesting
night of course being the queen that she
is B let Taylor finish I would like to
thank
all the fans on Twitter and Myspace I
thought that I couldn't Love Beyonce
more tonight and then I I think tonight
happened and it was just wonderful in
the aftermath yay's might grab turned
into one of the most infamous moments in
pop culture history I think that Kanye
mints well it wasn't executed properly
you know
um and Taylor deserved that moment pink
who was in the audience called Kanye a
POS on Twitter and it was a hot topic on
The View it was kind of a bullying
moment yeah you don't do that to kids I
was like oh
that was an escape but this was not so
tough now are you Kanye West is it just
so happens you messed with the wrong
tailors that's lotner finding closure on
SNL two months after the award show
[Music]
so to recap hindsight's 2020 for the
actor but he'll always be part of one of
the most talked about VMA moments of all
time so yeah that would be the moment
foreign